ALEX: So I'm Alex from Bite
Sci-Zed, and I have
synesthesia.
And so I have grapheme two-color
synesthesia, which
means that my digits in
my numbers have color.
And a lot of times this is due
to the actual digits of the
number themselves.
Because each digit from zero
to nine has its own color.
The colors of numbers above nine
actually have to do with
their factors as well.
And so things in the three, six,
nine series, so multiples
of three, are actually
my warm colors.
So three is red, six is orange,
and nine is sort of a
very dark red maroon.
BRADY HARAN: Go from
zero for me?
ALEX: OK, yeah.
Absolutely.
Zero is sort of a
clear number.
One is simultaneously
white and black.
Two is green.
Three is red.
Four is blue.
Five is very black.
Six is orange.
Seven is yellow.
Eight is sort of
a darker blue.
Nine is a very dark maroon.
And then once you get into
things like 10, they're
simultaneously white
and black.
A lot of the two and three digit
numbers have to do with
their actual digits.
So things like 20 will be very
predominately green, because
they start with a two.
However, that 20 is actually a
little bit more clear or white
and black as well, because it
has the 2 times the 10, which
is simultaneously
white and black.
It also has a little bit of the
four thrown in, so it's a
slight blue tinge as well as
sort of a little bit of that
black from the five.
BRADY HARAN: So when you're
telling me this and you're
envisaging it, what's happening
in your brain?
Are you seeing the number five
that color or are you just
seeing a color?
ALEX: I'm actually seeing the
number in that color.
But I try and describe it to
people as the space in my
brain that it occupies is the
same space that it would
occupy if you tried to visualize
a pumpkin right now
because I said it to you.
You don't see it in the world
in front of you, but you see
it in a space in your head.
And so the numbers in my
head are that color.
BRADY HARAN: So when you were
counting through the numbers
for me a minute ago, in your
mind's eye, was there like a
white background and then there
was a number five of
that color like the
shape of the five?
Or was your mind's eye just
going, oh, that color, like a
flash to color?
ALEX: It is sort of that
number in its color.
I think I've developed such a
strong visualization to them
that now the numbers and the
colors are the same almost.
So if I see something like four
red blocks on a table,
it's intrinsically
wrong to me.
Because it should be either
four blue blocks
or three red blocks.
It doesn't cause me problems,
but it absolutely interacts
with the way that I interact
with my world.
So it helps with how I visualize
math problems.
And it also sort of helps with
how I look at the world around
me and classify things
and remember things.
BRADY HARAN: Does it
make you better?
ALEX: I don't think it makes
me better at all.
I think it's something actually
that a lot of people
have, but they don't realize
that they have.
I didn't realize that I was
doing this until my freshman
year of college when a professor
called out, does
anyone in this classroom see
numbers with colors?
And my first response
is, that's stupid.
Numbers don't have colors,
they have personalities.
And then I realized that the
personalities I was equating
with my numbers were
their colors.
Nine was a very angry
number, because it
was so dark and red.
Whereas twos and fours were much
happier numbers because
they were cool blues
and greens.
BRADY HARAN: When you've done
a bit of research and found
out about other people with this
condition, or skill, or
whatever we're going to call it,
do they associate the same
colors with numbers or is
everyone different?
ALEX: No, absolutely not.
That's the best thing that I've
found, is that sharing my
numbers with colors is I have
this strong reaction from
other synesthetes who go,
no, absolutely not.
Five is the brightest yellow
you've ever seen, and six is a
dark blue, and how dare you
have different numbers?
And I think that's the best part
of it, is that everyone
interacts with these numbers
and colors in a
very different way.
-13, the most important thing
is tremendous good luck.
It's bad luck for everybody
else, but for a magician,
somebody who likes--
-It's prime.
What was the other thing?
This is called not
respecting your
favorite number well enough.
ALEX: But when I was 13, I
decided that was silly and so
the last one stuck.
And so my favorite number
has always stuck at 27.
-Well, it's even.
And it's the lowest
even number.